there's no question whatsoever that
you've definitely made some outrageous
claims like you know and uh and i like
how you're candid about it you say like
you know i'm i'm i'm not particularly
humble i'm kind of narcissistic and i
deserve to be i like that that that line
you know it's like you've pulled off
some awesome stuff in your life you
deserve to to feel like you're the man
right well i'll tell you why steve steve
always because
it's because when when you go so many
years
when you're out and you're down and
people are are laughing at you and
humiliating you
publicly and it's in the kind of
spectrum that we deal with
you know
with every type of individual you can
think of
once once you do fix your life right
like we did
we're proud of it and we want we're
grateful for it proud grateful right and
i'm also very i i feel a lot more humble
too you know as time goes on but at the
same time i'm like yo
don't disrespect me because you don't
know how hard the work was for me to get
to where i am today sure and so yeah i
am proud of these things yeah i am proud
because without you guys
also i wouldn't be able to have this
stuff the fans the fans are our boss
they're our family but they're to me and
they're but our they're our bosses you
know because they pay us right you know
so i want to show to them hey
look
i i i've worked really hard the last
four years to change my life around i've
stayed clean and sober off of huffing
every single day since i graduated from
rehab being there for 90 days
and that's something
that i i find that you know the general
public or media doesn't shine light on
they want me to be the villain i'm
naturally a villain so you don't have to
pick i'm i have a nickname they call me
the joker right because i've been
bullied
so much
right so
i'm the joker bro if if people want to
play them with me you won't play with my
emotions i'm gonna paint my face and i'm
gonna show you who's boss i'm gonna
scare the [ __ ] out of you because
you you pissed me off and you you and
people can
people on instagram live and all these
platforms
they're being [ __ ] man they're not
doing anything about it they're acting
like they're ignoring it when they
really need to be calling out these
people and making holding them
accountable i think that that what i'm
hearing from you is is a
a a good strong argument for just not
paying attention to like comments and
stuff because like with like people like
you and i we have enough people
following us yeah that there's
of course there's gonna be people
talking [ __ ] in there like if i like i
i'm never gonna win if i go through
reading all the comments no no i don't
read that it's more so when i like go on
instagram you know and then the live
comments and i'm like listening to my
music and i'm trying to promote
something and then they're on there
saying oh you look like you have aids or
you're dying you're a crackhead you're
huffing again you you know you and then
just
you know except and it's back to back to
back to back all from these smear
campaign bot accounts but you know what
i'm talking about with about accounts
yeah i don't really do lives but what i
do but if you did you'd see
what i do do now is uh i go on the live
chat for when we premiere the episode of
the podcast on youtube
so uh yeah that'd be cool if you went on
the live chat for this one when it
premieres oh well oh yeah he's going to
have a clue absolutely yeah yeah um
because i'm controversial i say it
the way it is i'm not you know what i
have a saying
i'm never going to be a prisoner to
anybody's perception of me good yeah
it's the way to be you get it right
sure you know yeah that's like because
then if you are you have no identity
you're constantly trying to be
what everyone else wants you to be
you're just trying to prove yourself and
trying to prove yourself yeah and all
that and that's just
that's just too much energy and too much
time spent
yeah well it's kind of like what steve
was saying like just ignoring those
comments and just kidding
yeah you know i've gotten to that point
where
i've
i kind of look over it but it's
entertaining for me too because listen
everybody says ignore ignore going
but we're not making a difference guys
if we're ignoring them if you're holding
people accountable and making them go on
facetime live and showing their face and
being like
for me i don't know you kind of give
them what they want they go to school
the next day they're like dude he put me
on his live like it was crazy i don't
put them on my i embarrass them and i
humiliate them right and i give them
what they deserve
some guy wrote a bad comment about me
and i saw it and i was like dude that
kind of hurt my feelings and he was like
oh my god i'm so sorry i didn't even
think you're going to read it like no
that doesn't you know it's like but i
feel like trolls and people need to be
held accountable because you can't you
get like
here's here's a saying for you silence
is the deadliest weapon yeah
yeah you're right no you're right you're
right
by acknowledging negativity it's like
you know pouring water to grow it and
feed it and nurture it right but i still
feel it
water to grow
i respect your your
uh your opinion about that but at the
same time
i see some negative [ __ ] it's block and
delete pal
i don't know what we call it washing
their mouth so
for me for some reason it's it's it's
it's much more heightened than other
people
it really is i i can't tell you like
look at the youtube videos guys i mean
come on yeah i'm sure the haters
that's true it's worse no it's it's it's
much it's much worse because i have all
the backstreet boy fans against me
because of what happened with nick
that's true oh man that's darling
i do lives all the time almost like a
reality show for people okay i make it
very like involved and involved and i
think that's where a lot of the extra
extra extra haters come from and you
know i don't give as much attention as
ice to them as
it seems like i'm saying
but
it pisses me off bro like like really
because then i think to myself
what if there's somebody that is a
professional
and a producer or something that's
watching this and you see this stuff
then
are they gonna believe it
yeah i don't know man exactly we don't
know we never know we never know if if
you get a if you get a comment from a
smear campaign person that says
oh
he's a pedophile or something right
which is like one of the number one
things they like to do to people to ruin
them claim that they're powerful oh he's
a pedophile and then you get and then
someone sees like
200 likes on that post
right well automatically they're going
to believe it but then if you go if you
click on the likes you'll see that their
bot accounts counts
mice and you know zero posts no
followers all they follow is me
right one followers it's just me they
pay attention to my every move and it's
scary yeah dude
thanks for watching that clip and if you
live in america there's a good chance
that this big badass tour bus is coming
to your town with my bucket list tour
what is it well it's an x-rated show
full of all the stuff that i would have
never have been allowed to do for
jackass and a lot of it is flagrantly
illegal so it's adults only and if you
live in any of these states then you
better go to stevo.com and check out my
tour schedule hurry up and get your
tickets too because it's selling out
everywhere
yeah dude
[Music]